okay we should be good can you guys hear
me um ok so a couple things as you guys
know I'm gonna I'm gonna keep an eye on
this on this thing here let me know if
you guys are having problems YouTube's
freaking primary server has been given
me a bit of a hassle so I want to make
sure that that everything is running the
way it should so if you guys start to
have problems if it starts to act up on
you make sure you guys let me know
what's going on so I hate it when this
happens when it's just like your nerve
and order mmm we have coffee by the way
so um one of the things that you guys
will notice on the screen um the video
hasn't loaded up yet I don't understand
why what in the heck it just says please
stand by starting soon it should have
already started by now
should have anywhere it's been like a
minute
what the hell
I don't get why it's not going yet
is it is it's not alive here what the
heck
what is going on YouTube come on guys
get it together all right I can't hit
the stop streaming button because it
won't be done for evidence so I don't
understand what in the hell is going on
come on youtube
this is ridiculous
you've got my thing set up and I've got
all kinds of stuff on here
everything is right
oh my god
it should have already started by now I
don't know why it hasn't
you